now we have to we're on a very very
strict clock here they will pull a cane
out and yank me off at the stage if I go
two seconds over my limit but we still
have about five minutes here I have been
told I can hear from all of you in a q a
we have microphones throughout this vast
Auditorium if anybody has a question
jump up now
ask your question we have a rule over at
the daily wire which I hate well I love
the daily wire but I hate this rule the
rule is if you disagree with me you get
to cut to the front of the line
I think if you disagree with me you
should be sent to Guantanamo Bay they
they disagree and they write the checks
so okay that's the rule if you disagree
you can get to the front of the line do
we have some questions
hi Michael my name is Sarah and I'm a
huge fan I'm kind of one of the only
Conservative Christian people in my
entire school do you have any advice to
not get beat to a pulp but still stand
up
oh
yes I do I do actually it's a great
first of all
coming to events like America Fest
that's a good start that's a pretty good
way to finally be around some
like-minded sensible people as you're
dealing with guidance counselors who
want to convince you you're a boy and
whatever other nonsense they do so
you're already obviously on the right
track you've got a good head on your
shoulders I think that you don't need to
be totally flamboyant about your views
you don't need to go out and have the
Maga hat on every single day of the week
you can maybe wear it three days a week
you know pick the classes you don't need
to be flamboyant about that you can be
confident you can actually learn from
the libs because every man truly is my
master and I can learn from him so you
have a great Advantage you can hear all
these crazy liberal arguments you can
have them challenge your views maybe
that will cause you to adjust some of
your views maybe it will it deepen your
own beliefs and you recognize why
they're so wrong but but you you can
learn from them in a way that they will
not be able to learn from you and then
this is crucial when you are call sold
out when you are put in a corner when
you are asked what do you believe that
is when you've got to stand firm you
have no other choice your question is
how do you stop them from beating you up
you're not going to stop them from
beating you up it's like that last scene
in Breaking Bad when you know the cop
brother is lying on the ground and he
says he turns to Walter White he says
Walter you're the smartest guy I know
you don't realize the guy made up his
mind 10 minutes ago it's not a question
of are you going to get beaten up in
public for your views that will happen
the question is are you gonna have the
courage and the Integrity to stand up
when the time comes and let's not forget
courage is not only a virtue it is the
prerequisite for all of the other
virtues without which they mean nothing
stand strong you're obviously already
doing a great job
all right I think we got time for one
more question unless I'm not as
long-winded then we'll have two more
questions
hi Michael it's great to see you again I
have a question about relationship
advice okay suppose that this is a girl
you like and you liked her for a year
and then only recently you better not
she got a boyfriend should you give up
on her or should you try to ask her out
anyways
[Applause]
great question great to see you again
my friend
just because there is a goalie does not
mean that you cannot score
you
this girl that you like she's not
married yet she's dating some guy that's
okay that's you know what I call that I
call that a challenge now
now maybe you know you try it doesn't
you know she it doesn't work out there's
plenty of other fish in the sea but
there's no reason you can't try
great question all right we do actually
have time for one more all right last
question
hello sir I have a question in regards
to uh careers I heard in California
there was a bill that was waiting to be
passed that could uh take the license
away from doctors that would spend miss
a spread misinformation about the
vaccine and potentially imprisoned them
I'm looking to go into medical school in
this next year and I'm a very die-hard
conservative and if I believe that my
patient shouldn't have a certain medical
procedure I would tell them so my
question is for people that suffer for
and might lose their careers or their
license or their livelihoods because of
what they believe in how are we gonna
move forward and still make a living
when you say that there they could be
punished for spreading misinformation
about the vaccine I assume what you mean
is that misinformation that the vaccine
is totally safe right that kind of
misinformation or maybe the
misinformation information that the
vaccine is very effective I don't know
there's a lot of misinformation that has
been spread about the vaccine it's all
been spread by Dr fauci and Joe Biden
maybe they will be punished in the state
of California probably not
probably not what do you do
what we're talking about is the very
theme of my speech what we're talking
about is the the regime that governs
what we can say how we can say it the
standards and Norms in our society we're
not going to get rid of all of those
norms and limits that's never happened
in any society ever so what we have to
do is engage in the political process if
there are prudent regulations against
scientific misinformation then we better
be damn well sure that it's actually
against misinformation and not true
information which means that California
Republicans need to go in there win
office change the rules fire the bad
guys and what can you do right now you
can vote with your feet and you can come
as I did I lived in California I fled
the reign of new Cellini I got out of
there there was a Michael shaped hole in
the wall I got out so fast I went to the
free state of Tennessee I breathed the
free air again it was beautiful you can
go to Florida you can go to Texas you
can go to real America and you can
celebrate your rights and your freedoms
and your traditional way of life and I
wish wish you the best of luck godspeed
God bless you all thank you so much for
having me
thank you